je vous le disais du monde entier
s'expriment la tristesse après la
disparition du saint-laurent les médias
étrangers ont consacré une large part
cette information à paris l'une de nos
équipes a recueilli le sentiment de
plusieurs professionnels l'atelier terre
robin de bouger les petites mains yves
saint laurent les a toujours respecté
pour leur habileté et leur patience et
la splendeur de leur travail dès la
création de sa maison le couturier a
fait appel aux bons services de jean
lesage une collaboration de 50 ans dont
le maître brodeur se souvient dans les
moindres détails et dit voyez le miroir
de de lalanne le le lustre de jacques
grange et le ciel de paris
je voudrais les baisses comme ça mais
c'est celle ci à l'aube c'est à midi où
c'est au crépuscule les trois vous il va
commencer par un bout et on a fait ça
voilà ce qui a été fait la fameuse veste
s'appelait hommage à ma maison ils sont
laurent l'homme qui aimait les femmes
afin de leur donner la liberté de faire
comme les hommes
pour beaucoup de ses contemporains cette
image là que l'on retiendra sans doute
c'est un style qui a contribué
sociologiquement et humainement a libéré
les femmes et à leur donner les armes
d'aujourd'hui qui sont les armes de la
communication qui sont les armes aussi
que je pense qu'ils étaient le plus beau
cadeau qui étaient les armes de la
masculinité qui l'a fait basculer dans
la féminité
moi j'ai ressenti ça avec un laurent
j'ai ressenti qu'il avait une un amour
particulier pour les femmes une espèce
de c'était pas un jeu pour lui c'était
il adorait fait ces femmes il adorait
les habiller et l'alimenter quant au
couturier en herbe
il leur sera impossible de ne pas faire
référence presque quotidiennement à yves
saint laurent
dès que l'on porte un costume va mettre
un tailleur pour aller travailler c'est
un tailleur pantalon effectivement ça
fait ça laurent on se souvient que c'est
lui qui a fait un défilé le 1er mangan
couleurs sur les podiums dont craint de
sages pour ça je pense que c'est des
beaux messages en tout cas pour la suite
disto l'auront il restera donc des
messages mais encore et surtout 50 ans
du nemo de vue indémodable un grand
monsieur s'est éteint mais les trois
lettres de son nom ont de longs jours
devant elle